la transmission potentielle du
coronavirus via les aérosols ne fait
plus de doute
l'agencé de santé publique du canada
vient de reconnaître à son tour d'où
l'importance d'une ventilation accrue
des bâtiments qu'ils soient grands ou
petits
qu'il soit pour s'y loger s'y instruire
où ils travaillent et ses bâtiments ont
une chose en commun avec nous il respire
[Musique]
on leur demande aujourd'hui de le faire
mieux et plus pour nous mettre à l'abri
d'un virus système de ventilation était
fait pour justement apporter une gêne
aux gens nettoyer l'eau contaminée la
poussière pitcho mais il n'y a jamais eu
une réflexion que le système soit
capable de réagir à une pandémie
[Musique]
mis à part les laboratoires et les
hôpitaux
jusqu'à quel point les bâtiments à usage
courant peuvent-ils s'adapter à de
nouvelles mesures de ventilation une
personne respire jusqu'à quinze mille
litres d'air par jour
la puissance du système mécanique de
ventilation en tient compte
dans les firmes de génie spécialisée en
ventilation les ingénieurs conçoivent
les systèmes en fonction de la
superficie du bâtiment mais aussi en
fonction du nombre de personnes qui s'y
trouvent une école savoir des tortues
elle doit être plus chez lui pour pour
une classe pour l'hôpital sont très
différentes les toons ventilation
dépendent de l'usagé que l'on fait dans
le bâtiment l'air qui alimentent ces
systèmes de ventilation et rarement
composé à 100% d'air neuf c'est plus
souvent un mélange de recycler der 9
par souci d'économie d'énergie dans un
bureau type on va introduire par exemple
entre 10 et 20 % d'air neuf à chaque
fois que les rues circulent dans la
pièce d'ailleurs la notion de
renouvellement de l'air et de
recirculation de l'air sont deux
concepts distincts dans quand on fait la
recirculation là on fait appel aux
filtration pour pouvoir éliminer un
maximum la présence de contaminants
dans une pièce par exemple où l'air
circule cinq fois à l'heure et qu'on
introduit chaque fois 20 % dernière cela
signifie que l'air il sera complètement
renouvelée une fois
mais les choses se sont bousculées avec
l'arrivée du coronavirus car avec lui
bien la probabilité qu'il se disperse
loin dans l'air quand on expire qu'on
parle ou qu'on tousse
après les appels successifs des
chercheurs dans le domaine
l'agencé de santé publique du canada
vient de reconnaître le rôle des
aérosols il va se former imaginons nous
comme un genre de nuages autour de la
personne infectée qui va contenir une
concentration de virus n'est pas encore
très clair mais qu'ils voient qu'on est
des virus sur des particules de
différentes tailles et le la ventilation
vaut jouer on est en effet de diluer
cette espèce de nuages là et surtout
d'éviter sa propagation dans une pièce à
l'intérieur par exemple par précaution
on veut donc ventilés davantage mais est
ce possible partout peut-on augmenter le
débit de l'air la quantité d'air neuf à
volonté se traduit celle d'augmenter le
débit aux systèmes haut débit total
distincts une possibilité d'augmenter le
pourcentage de neuf dans le système
social est toujours possible
le débit total des systèmes sur deviez
difficile dans ce laboratoire de
l'université concordia
on est toutes sortes de paramètres de
filtration et de ventilation et ce qui
limite l'augmentation du débit mis à
part la taille des conduits ce sont
souvent les ventilateurs
[Musique]
les ventilateurs sont utilisés pour une
utilisation utilisation très spécifique
scellé sous utilisé ce procès les soeurs
et irisée sais pas vous donc il faut
toujours rester dans une zone optimale
de l'utilisation de 26 ans qui va
déterminer si on peut ajouter un filtre
plus efficace
on sait que les filtres existe en
différentes tailles épaisseur
chacun a une capacité de filtration qui
lui est propre ça dépend du diamètre des
fibres et de leur niveau de
chevauchement vous voyez des plis lancer
de plus sérieux en quelque sorte pour
augmenter la surface de filtration des
plus grands ennemis à la dispersion des
particules virales
ce sont les filtres et pas à haute
efficacité dans les bâtiments ils sont
plus souvent utilisés là où les risques
de contamination sont plus importants
comme les hôpitaux ou certains
laboratoires
ailleurs c'est plutôt des filtres 9 un
acronyme anglais pour désigner un autre
standards d'efficacité de filtres
l'échelle va de 1 avait peint étant les
plus performants dans la plupart des
édifices
ça va en général demeurent 8 à 13
mais depuis l'apparition du qoran à
virus la société américaine des
ingénieurs en chauffage et réfrigération
lacherie recommande d'utiliser au moins
des meurtres est là où c'est possible
[Musique]
c'est la ventilation conçu pour utiliser
des mères vous par exemple louis xiii
bah si on va aller plus loin il faut
s'assurer que ne vont pas provoquer une
résistance plus le film très performant
plus ils créent une résistance au
passage de l'air lui il faut de
puissance pour pousser l'air et
maintenir de même débit selon la
capacité du système de ventilation
installés dans le bâtiment
c'est possible qu'on ne dispose pas de
cette force moteur supplémentaire ce qui
peut limiter le niveau de filtration
l'autre stratégie on utilise aussi à
ceux des marais les systèmes plus tôt le
matin pour purger le bâtiment est plus
possible et la même chose à la fin de la
journée dans les écoles
le problème se présentent autrement si
leur construction date ils n'ont pas de
système de filtration et de ventilation
un peu comme la majorité de nos maisons
pour reynald et vieille école
on l'aimé ou non du show qu'on laisse
tant les systèmes de ventilation des
anciennes écoles qui ont pas encore été
rénové par les fenêtres vraiment qu'ils
se rendent à solution pour augustin ce
qui est vraiment important c'est de
passer à la ventilation dans le sens de
bouger l'armée vraiment dans le sens de
diluer les contaminants donc d'avoir un
apport d'air frais à l'intérieur d'une
pièce
dans ces conditions un ventilateur de
plafond ou sur pied n'est pas l'idéal
il ne fait que brasser l'air vicié
il faut faire attention aux risques une
personne par exemple qui éternue ray que
sa chope à transporter ailleurs à
d'autres personnes ça peut être plus
risqués une autre option des
purificateurs d'air portable certains
fonctionnent avec des filtres et pas
c'est un compromis
l'herbe ici est filtré mais le système
n'est traduit pas d'air neuf
enfin on doit se rappeler que la
ventilation ne règle pas tout
il ne fait que s'ajouter aux portes du
masque et aux mesures de distanciation
physique pour réduire la propagation du
virus
[Musique]
huit mois après l'arrivée de ce nouvel
intrus et avec le confinement hivernale
qui s'en vient force est de constater
que nos bâtiments auront besoin comme
nous de prendre un peu d'air
[Musique]